inotropic receptors are ligand-gated
iron Channel whereas metapotropic
receptors act via gpcr signaling let's
look at a post synapse to understand the
ionotropic receptors ionotropic
receptors are ligand-gated iron channels
so when ligand binds it opens and allows
the cationic influx that lead to the
change in the membrane potential and
this is the postsynaptic response in
case of metabotropic receptors they are
gpcrs so after ligand binding the G
protein gets activated and it eventually
moves to the adenine it cyclist and
eventually activates the enzyme
adenylate cyclist which triggers the
second messenger response by generating
cyclic amp cyclic amp can lead to
plethora of Downstream events one
example of metabotropic receptor is the
dopamine receptors the D1 dopamine type
of receptors are like GS coupled and the
D2 dopamine receptors are GI coupled
which inhibits adenylate cyclase and D1
activates adenylate cyclist watch video